From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Well, so the story starts where I get a call. It's interesting, I remember this very well. I was sitting at my desk.
事情是这样的，故事开始于我接到一个电话。很有意思，我记得非常清楚。当时我正坐在办公桌前。
This is John Diedrich, a reporter who covers law enforcement for the Milwaukee Journal Sentinel.
这位是约翰·迪德里奇，他是《密尔沃基哨兵日报》负责报道执法部门的记者。
I get a call. And it was from a landlord, a guy named Dave Salkin. And Dave Salkin owns this place that he, unbeknownst to him, rented to the ATF. Didn't know who they were, they were undercover agents. And they had trashed his place, and they were behind on rent. They had threatened him. And I said, where are you, I'm coming right now.
我接到了一个电话。是一位房东打来的，他叫戴夫·萨尔金。戴夫·萨尔金拥有一处房产，他不知情地租给了美国烟酒枪炮及爆炸物管理局（ATF）。他不知道这些人是谁，他们是卧底特工。他们把他的房子弄得一团糟，而且还拖欠房租。他们甚至威胁他。我说，你在哪儿，我现在就过去。
While they were undercover, agents from the Bureau of Alcohol, Tobacco, Firearms and Explosives basically ripped up his place. Salkin said at the time that they owed $15,000 in damages and back rent. Later he said it was more. When he tried to collect, they didn't pay up. In fact, an ATF lawyer warned him that if he kept asking for the money, it could be seen as harassing federal agents.
在进行卧底行动期间，来自美国烟酒枪炮及爆炸物管理局（ATF）的特工几乎把他的房子拆毁了。萨尔金当时表示，他们欠下1.5万美元的损失费和房租。后来他又说金额不止这些。当他试图讨债时，对方根本不付钱。事实上，一名ATF的律师还警告他，如果他继续讨要这笔钱，可能会被视为骚扰联邦特工。
So he took me through the place, and he showed me the damage. There were door frames that were broken, holes in the wall, a toilet that had overflowed and ruined some carpeting on the floor-- they grew marijuana plants, which later they got criticism from headquarters being an unauthorized prop-- and a bunch of junk that was left behind in the operation.
于是他带我参观了那个地方，给我看了损坏的情况。门框被拆坏了，墙上有洞，马桶溢水导致地板上的地毯被毁——他们还在里面种植大麻，后来遭到总部批评，称这是未经授权的道具——还有行动中留下的一堆垃圾。
What John had stumbled onto was an ATF operation of such blinding incompetence that it is kind of hard to fathom. The Attorney General later called what happened at this store and others like it very troubling. The ATF had set up a fake business, a front, in this out of the way warehousey space not near other stores. Raquel Rutledge was John's reporting partner on the story.
约翰偶然发现的是一起ATF行动，其无能程度令人难以置信。司法部长后来形容这家店以及其他类似店面发生的事情“非常令人不安”。ATF设立了一家伪装企业，一个掩护据点，位于这个偏僻的仓库区域，远离其他商铺。拉克尔·拉特利奇是约翰在这篇报道中的合作记者。
It was called Fearless Distributing. And it was kind of a hip hop clothing store, also sold some drug paraphernalia. But the real goal was to actually buy guns and drugs.
这家店叫“无畏分销”（Fearless Distributing）。它表面上是一家嘻哈服装店，也卖一些毒品用具。但真正的目标其实是购买枪支和毒品。
To get the guns off the street and to catch people selling them illegally, also to do drug busts.
目的是为了清除街头枪支，抓捕非法贩卖枪支的人，同时也为了打击毒品交易。
If you looked to be a real customer coming in to buy clothing from the store and so forth, they would try to scare you away, because the idea was they really wanted only sort of shady individuals that were willing to bring them guns and drugs. And so--
如果你看起来像个进店买衣服的真正顾客，他们会试图把你吓走，因为他们的初衷是只吸引那些愿意给他们提供枪支和毒品的卑鄙之徒。所以——
Wow, a weird market to try to cater to.
哇，这可真是一个奇怪的营销对象。
Yeah. It's not Retail 101. Their cover story was that they were a motorcycle gang from New York that had stolen all of this stuff off a truck.
是的，这不是零售业入门教程。他们的掩护身份是来自纽约的一个摩托车帮派，声称这些货物都是从卡车上偷来的。
All this stuff, the hip hop clothing, that is. The agents would tell customers that they wanted to buy guns and drugs. And they left conversation starters, like gun brochures and magazines, lying around on the counters.
我是指那些嘻哈服装。特工们会告诉顾客他们想买枪和毒品。他们还把枪支宣传册和杂志等“话题引子”随意扔在柜台上。
And they distributed flyers with the store's logo, which was a skull with angel wings made from assault rifles and knives with the words Buy, Sell, Trade, wink, wink. Federal agents actually ripped off the logo from the Sylvester Stallone film, The Expendables , possibly in violation of their copyright. The whole store was set up with secret cameras, so everything that happened was filmed to use as evidence later.
他们还散发带有商店标志的传单，那标志是一个头骨，翅膀由突击步枪和刀具组成，上面写着“买、卖、换”，还要挤眉弄眼。联邦特工实际上是抄袭了西尔维斯特·史泰龙电影《敢死队》的标志，这可能侵犯了版权。整家店都安装了秘密摄像头，发生的一切都被拍摄下来，作为日后的证据。
But right from the start, like the most basic thing that you would think that the ATF would get right, the price of guns, even there they had problems. ATF policy was to pay whatever just to get the guns off the street. But that led to complications.
但从一开始，连最基本的事情，也就是你认为ATF应该搞清楚的事情——枪支的价格——他们都出了问题。ATF的政策是不惜一切代价把枪支从街头收缴上来。但这导致了复杂的问题。
Right. I mean, when you looked at what the street value of these were, they were paying really beyond, well beyond retail, well beyond mint value in these cases, I mean, to the point that people were able to go and buy guns from stores such as Gander Mountain and bring them right there. There was one gun that they paid $2,100 for, and just the day before the individual had bought it for $700 at a store.
没错。当你看到这些枪的街头价值时，他们支付的价格远超零售价，在某些情况下甚至远超枪支本身的原厂价值。他们给的价格高到什么程度呢？人们可以直接去甘德山等枪店买新枪，然后直接带过来。有一支枪他们花了2100美元购买，而那个人前一天才在商店里以700美元买到它。
I mean, it was really spurring folks to go out and steal. And neighbors we talked to around River West said they did also see an uptick in burglaries in their neighborhood.
我的意思是，这确实是在刺激人们去偷窃。我们在里弗韦斯特区采访的邻居们说，他们也确实注意到附近地区的入室盗窃案有所增加。
Wait, wait. I just want to be sure that I've got this right. So they move in, they set up an operation to buy stolen stuff, and what that does is that it increases, it creates an incentive for people to steal. And so they're creating crime.
等等，等等。我只是想确认一下我没听错。所以他们搬进去，设立了一个购买赃物的行动，而这产生的后果就是增加了、创造了一种让人们去偷窃的诱因。所以他们是在制造犯罪。
That's what we found to happen. Yes.
这就是我们发现的情况。是的。
Raquel and John found one guy, Brandon Gladney, who had no record of fencing guns before this. But they say he apparently started in the gun business because of the incredibly high prices that ATF was willing to pay for firearms.
拉克尔和约翰找到了一个人，布兰登·格拉德尼，他在这次行动之前没有任何非法倒卖枪支的记录。但他们说，显然他开始从事枪支生意，完全是因为ATF愿意为枪支支付极高的价格。
But so many other details about this operation seem poorly conceived. Like, for example, if their cover is they're starting a store, why not have a sign or a storefront, like a real store? Why pose as a white biker gang? Would that really fit in in a neighborhood that is mostly black people and hipsters?
但关于这次行动的许多其他细节似乎也构思拙劣。比如，如果他们的掩护身份是开一家商店，为什么不弄个招牌或店面，像个真正的商店呢？为什么装扮成白人摩托帮？这在黑人为主、嬉皮士聚集的社区里真的合适吗？
This thing was so suspicious. I mean, OK, so you're on a dead end street. There's no traffic that comes by. We did speak to the UPS guy who was coming through the neighborhood. This was interesting.
这事儿实在太可疑了。我的意思是，好吧，你待在一条死胡同里。没有任何人流经过。我们确实采访了在该社区配送的UPS快递员。这很有意思。
And early on, he said, when the ATF agents first opened up, he stopped in on them and said, I'm from UPS. I see you guys, Fearless Distributing. I'm happy to open an account for you. And the agent in charge quickly said, no, we're not going to be receiving or sending anything. And he was like, but your name is Fearless Distributing. And so from the beginning--
他在早些时候说，当ATF特工刚开业时，他进去找他们，说：“我是UPS的。我看到你们是‘无畏分销’。我很乐意为你们开个账户。”负责的特工很快说：“不，我们不会接收或发送任何东西。”快递员当时就想，但你们名字叫“无畏分销”啊。所以从一开始——
How are you going to do the distributing without ever getting a package?
如果不收发任何包裹，你们怎么做“分销”呢？
[LAUGHS] Yeah, right. Right.
[笑] 是啊，没错。没错。
For supposed criminals they didn't seem too concerned with drawing attention to themselves. They threw barbecues and played loud music behind the building. Neighbors noticed customers walking in with guns and walking out empty-handed.
作为所谓的罪犯，他们似乎并不担心引起注意。他们在建筑后面搞烧烤，播放震耳欲聋的音乐。邻居们注意到顾客带着枪走进去，出来时却两手空空。
And they were robbed. These agents whose job it was to get guns out of the hands of criminals had three guns that were stolen out of an agent's car while he was parked at a coffee shop. These included a fully automatic rifle. This is a machine gun, the kind that normally only law enforcement and military can legally have.
而且他们自己也被抢了。这些职责本应是从罪犯手中缴获枪支的特工，却在一家咖啡店外被偷走了留在特工车里的三把枪。其中包括一把全自动步枪。这是一挺机枪，通常只有执法部门和军队才能合法拥有。
Not long after that, the store itself was burglarized of $39,000 in clothes, jewelry, and merch, reportedly, because the ATF had not bothered to do much to secure the store and just did not seem to care. Nobody was minding the store, literally.
在那之后不久，这家店本身也遭到了入室盗窃，据报道丢失了3.9万美元的服装、珠宝和商品，因为ATF根本没费心去保护商店，似乎根本不在乎。真的，当时根本没人看店。
The ATF had no working burglar alarm on their building. So it was sort of, instead of a smash and grab, it was just this sort of like slow burglary. The neighbors report at one point, once they were able to get in-- again, no burglar alarm-- they kept the door propped open with a shoe. And they were just kind of taking stuff out.
ATF的大楼里没有安装能正常工作的防盗报警器。所以与其说是“打砸抢”，不如说是一场缓慢的入室盗窃。邻居们报告说，有一次，当他们能够进入时——再次强调，没有报警器——他们就一直用鞋子顶着门。他们就这样把东西往外搬。
And the word sort of spread. Hey, this place is just open. Nobody's there. We can just go get stuff. And at one point they just pulled up a U-Haul. And they were just sort of emptying this. And this is over several days. And then even--
消息就这样传开了。“嘿，那地方开了门，里面没人。我们可以直接进去拿东西。”有一次他们甚至直接开了一辆U-Haul货车过来。他们就这样把店清空了。这过程持续了好几天。甚至——
Renting a U-Haul is such a crazy move, because is it means that somebody had to go and decide, I'm going to rent a truck. That's how slow this burglary is, that you can do a rental.
租一辆U-Haul搬家货车真是个疯狂的举动，因为这意味着有人得专门去决定“我要去租辆车”。这盗窃进行得是有多慢，以至于你还有时间去租车。
Yeah, exactly. And there's no sort of concern that you're going to be busted at that point, and just say, OK, I can only carry so much in my arms. Let's get something bigger. Let's get a U-Haul.
是的，完全正确。而且他们根本不担心会被抓，只是觉得，好吧，我胳膊只能拿这么多。让我们弄个大的。去租辆U-Haul吧。
The same day the burglary was reported, an ATF ballistic shield, the kind that they would use to raid a house or something, was turned in by a scrapper at a Milwaukee police station. One item that was just left lying around in the store after the robbery for anybody to pick up and read-- it was there when reporter John Diedrich walked through-- was a secret ATF document listing the names of undercover agents, their undercover vehicles from several law enforcement agencies in Milwaukee.
在盗窃案被报告的同一天，一个ATF的防弹盾牌——那种他们突袭房屋时会用的东西——被一个废品收购商送到了密尔沃基警察局。在抢劫案发生后，店里随处可见的一份秘密ATF文件里列着卧底特工的名字和他们在密尔沃基多个执法机构的卧底车辆信息——这简直是谁都可以捡起来读的——当记者约翰·迪德里奇走访现场时，那份文件还在那里。
After the burglary, the ATF shut down Fearless Distributing. And what results did they get from their fake storefront hip hop clothing business? How many people were arrested? An ATF spokesman said it was a success, quote, "in many respects." Over 140 guns taken off the street, also 34 people were charged.
入室盗窃发生后，ATF关闭了“无畏分销”。他们从这个伪装成嘻哈服装店的行动中得到了什么结果？有多少人被捕？一位ATF发言人称这是“在许多方面”的一次成功。从街头收缴了超过140支枪，同时起诉了34人。
But as John and Raquel point out, these were mostly for low-level drug and gun crimes. Median sentence, they calculated, was two years. And nearly half the cases were dropped or resulted in no prison time. And despite having video surveillance, John says the ATF incorrectly identified and arrested three suspects.
但正如约翰和拉克尔所指出的，这些大多是低级别的毒品和枪支犯罪。他们计算出的中位刑期是两年。近一半的案件被撤销或判处缓刑。而且尽管有视频监控，约翰表示ATF错误地识别并逮捕了三名嫌疑人。
And the alibi for one of them was that he was in prison at the time that they said that he was doing this operation on an ATF charge. So, you know, you would think that they would know they had busted him on an earlier AFT case.
其中一人的不在场证明是，在他们指控他参与ATF这次行动时，他其实正因之前的ATF指控在监狱服刑。所以，你本以为他们应该知道自己之前曾抓过他才对。
ATF would not tell the newspaper or us how much the operation cost the government. Things can get tricky pretty fast when you try to pretend to be something that you are not. To set up a fake gun-buying ring there are all kinds of details, like, you know, get an alarm system for your fake, fell-off-a-truck merch.
ATF拒绝告诉报社或我们这次行动花费了政府多少钱。当你试图假装成你自己以外的人时，事情很快就会变得很棘手。建立一个虚假的购枪团伙涉及各种细节，比如，你知道，给你的那些假货——那些“从卡车掉下来的”商品——装个防盗系统。
Today on our radio show stories of people setting up fake operations in three very different settings, including very surprising things happening at other ATF storefronts across the country. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目将讲述人们在三个截然不同的背景下设立虚假行动的故事，包括在全国其他ATF店面发生的非常令人惊讶的事情。请继续收听。
Act One, WTF, ATF? So a funny thing happened after John and Raquel wrote a series of stories about the ATF's fake business, Fearless Distributing, in Milwaukee. The United States Congress got involved.
第一幕，“搞什么鬼，ATF？”在约翰和拉克尔撰写了一系列关于ATF在密尔沃基开设伪装企业“无畏分销”的报道后，发生了一件有趣的事。美国国会介入了。
ATF came and briefed Congress. And they said, this is a legitimate tactic that has worked well in other cities. And it's just a problem in Milwaukee.
ATF向国会做了简报。他们说，这是一种在其他城市运行良好的合法策略，只是在密尔沃基出了点问题。
I acknowledge, Mr. Chairman and members of the committee, that there were deficiencies in our execution and management of some past activities in certain storefronts.
主席先生，委员会成员们，我承认我们在过去某些店面行动的执行和管理上存在不足。
This is the director of the ATF, B. Todd Jones, talking to the House Committee on Oversight and Government Reform. As recently as April of this year, ATF and Jones were still defending ATF storefront operations across the country. Jones says that there were 37 of them since 2009.
这是ATF局长B·托德·琼斯在众议院监督与政府改革委员会上的讲话。就在今年四月，ATF和琼斯仍在为全美的ATF店面行动进行辩护。琼斯表示，自2009年以来，他们一共开设了37家这样的店面。
As a result of our storefront operations in Albuquerque, Atlanta, Milwaukee, Pensacola, Portland, and Wichita, over 250 defendants have been convicted and over 1,300 firearms recovered. These convictions and the firearms recoveries undoubtedly made the communities and the people who live there safer.
由于我们在阿尔伯克基、亚特兰大、密尔沃基、彭萨科拉、波特兰和威奇托的店面行动，已有超过250名被告被定罪，回收了超过1300支枪支。这些定罪和枪支回收无疑使社区和居住在那里的人们更加安全。
And so we said, OK, well, let's test that premise. And that's when we looked around the country.
于是我们说，好吧，让我们验证一下这个前提。那就是我们审视全国各地的时候。
And as we started looking, really, truly, we came back to one other-- you're not going to believe this. I mean, we were shocked. I don't think we expected to find this going on. Absolutely not, did we expect to find that it would go on elsewhere, because you can't imagine this would be part of a playbook or an MO of a federal agency. So it was stunning to find. Had they been burglarized? Did they trash the landlord's place?
当我们开始调查时，真的，我们回到了一处——你绝对不敢相信。我的意思是，我们感到震惊。我不认为我们预料到会发现这种情况。绝对没预料到这种情况会发生在其他地方，因为你无法想象这竟然是联邦机构的剧本或惯用手段。发现这些令人震惊。他们也被抢了吗？他们也把房东的地方搞砸了吗？
We found in Portland the lady just said, I am so glad you called. She said, I have not known what to do. She said, they left my place in shambles. She had photos of what they left it like-- I mean, like a college fraternity or something. Just trash everywhere, they tore out some walls and they rewired some stuff and caused a leaky roof. She estimates her damages were probably $20,000 roughly, $20,000, $25,000. So that, you think, how does that happen? Is that, again, part of the playbook?
我们在波特兰发现，那位女士说：“我真高兴你打来电话。我不知道该怎么办。”她说，“他们把我的地方弄得一片狼藉。”她有他们离开时的照片——我的天，就像大学联谊会什么的。到处都是垃圾，他们拆了一些墙，重新布了一些线，导致屋顶漏水。她估计损失大约是2万美元，2万到2.5万美元。所以你觉得，这怎么可能发生？这也是剧本的一部分吗？
Raquel and John looked into ATF storefronts in Wichita, Portland, Oregon, Pensacola, Albuquerque, Atlanta, and Phoenix. Some of the Milwaukee problems they found examples of in those other cities? Agents paying extra high prices for guns, buying stolen goods, criminals committing burglaries in the neighborhoods around the stores and then selling the stuff to the ATF. Raquel and John say that the quality of the convictions from these operations around the country, the kinds of people that the ATF was catching were mostly small fry, just like in Milwaukee. The ATF store in Pensacola was robbed just like the Milwaukee store was, twice.
拉克尔和约翰调查了ATF在威奇托、波特兰、彭萨科拉、阿尔伯克基、亚特兰大和凤凰城的店面。他们在其他城市发现了与密尔沃基类似的问题？特工支付过高价格买枪、购买赃物、犯罪分子在商店周围社区入室盗窃，然后把东西卖给ATF。拉克尔和约翰说，这些全美行动的定罪质量——ATF抓获的那些人大多是小角色，就像在密尔沃基一样。ATF在彭萨科拉的商店也像密尔沃基那家一样被抢了，而且是两次。
Once surprising finding? Several storefronts were located near schools and churches. This came up in the trial of an ATF defendant in Lakeland, Florida.
一个令人惊讶的发现？有几家店面位于学校和教堂附近。这在佛罗里达州莱克兰市的一场ATF被告审判中被提出来了。
The very first question from the jury when they were deliberating was, is it legal for federal agents to open up a gun- and drug-buying operation within 1,000 feet of a school, because that seems illegal. That seems like that should not be allowed. That's what federal law is intended to do, is keep those criminals who are bringing guns and drugs in away from the school.
陪审团在讨论时的第一个问题是：“联邦特工在学校1000英尺内开设枪支和毒品购买行动合法吗？”因为这看起来不合法。这看起来是不应该被允许的。联邦法律的本意就是让那些带来枪支和毒品的罪犯远离学校。
Yeah, it is illegal for law enforcement to do that. But in Portland, Oregon, John and Raquel found the ATF agent who set up the storefront operation there said that when they rented their place, he entered from the back and didn't notice a school across the street.
是的，执法部门这样做是不合法的。但在俄勒冈州波特兰，约翰和拉克尔发现，在那里设立店面行动的ATF特工说，当他们租下那地方时，他是从后门进入的，没注意到街对面有一所学校。
They said, we didn't know the school was there, which is damning to their operational planning. How do you not know a school is across the street from your store? It turned out to be very helpful in their charging decisions later on.
他们说，“我们不知道学校在那里”，这对他们的行动规划来说简直是致命的。你怎么可能不知道你的商店对面就是学校？这后来在他们的控罪决定中显得非常有“用处”。
Helpful because?
有“用处”是因为？
Well, because selling guns or drugs within 1,000 feet of a school, a church, or other protected place is an enhanced penalty. It's also eligible for federal prosecution.
因为在学校、教堂或其他受保护地点1000英尺内贩卖枪支或毒品会加重处罚。它也符合联邦起诉的条件。
But probably the most outrageous ATF tactic that John and Raquel uncovered, the tactic that seemed to horrify Congress the most, was something they found in several cities. The ATF hired people at their fake stories who had a low IQs or were developmentally disabled, mentally impaired, and talked them into committing crimes, like a 20-year-old in Wichita named Tony Bruner.
但约翰和拉克尔发现的、最令人愤慨的ATF手段，似乎让国会最感到恐惧的手段，是他们在几个城市都发现的情况。ATF在他们的虚假商店雇佣了那些智商较低或有发育障碍、精神受损的人，并怂恿他们犯罪，比如威奇托市一个叫托尼·布鲁纳的20岁青年。
So he cleaned up the store. He swept. He helped stock the shelves and so forth. And then as they talked to him, they said, hey, can you go get us guns, get us guns, get us guns.
他负责打扫商店。他扫地。他帮着给货架上货等等。然后当他们和他谈话时，他们说，“嘿，你能帮我们弄枪吗，给我们弄枪，给我们弄枪。”
And he trusted them. And they would buy him McDonald's and tell him he was doing a great job and keep leaning on him to get guns. He was not a gun dealer. This person was not anybody in the gun business. But he ended up being able to find some folks that could bring him some guns. And then they turned around and charged him.
他信任他们。他们会给他买麦当劳，告诉他干得好，并不断施压让他去弄枪。他不是枪贩子。这个人根本不是枪支行业里的人。但最终他确实找到了些人可以给他弄枪。然后他们转身就把他抓了。
Charged him on 17 gun and drug counts.
以17项枪支和毒品罪名起诉了他。
I mean, even after the arrest Tony Bruner thought that he should call what he thought was his boss, who turns out to be the ATF agents, to help bail him out, because he still doesn't, because of his intellectual capacity-- limited-- he does not understand that they're federal agents, and that he's in a whole lot of trouble.
我的意思是，即使在被捕后，托尼·布鲁纳还觉得他应该打电话给那个他以为是老板的人——结果竟然是ATF特工——来帮他保释，因为由于他有限的智力水平，他根本不明白这些人是联邦特工，而他自己正陷入巨大的麻烦。
Tony Bruner pled guilty on one charge, was given a three-year sentence. In Milwaukee, at Fearless Distributing, ATF agents hired a man who'd been brain damaged as a baby, Chauncey Wright. Though to say hired implies that they paid him a salary. Like Tony Bruner, Chauncey seemed to be working in violation of all federal and state minimum wage laws. Agents would just give him $20 now and then, cigarettes, clothing from the store, an occasional beer or brat. They'd also hang out together, he says, watch movies, watch The Sopranos. Chauncey was closest to an agent that he knew as Mike.
托尼·布鲁纳对一项指控认罪，被判处三年监禁。在密尔沃基的“无畏分销”，ATF特工雇佣了一个婴儿时期就大脑受损的人，钱西·赖特。虽然说“雇佣”意味着他们支付了工资。像托尼·布鲁纳一样，钱西的工作似乎违反了所有联邦和州的最低工资法。特工们只是偶尔给他20美元、香烟、店里的衣服，偶尔给他一瓶啤酒或香肠。他们也经常聚在一起，他说，看电影，看《黑道家族》。钱西和一位他称为“迈克”的特工关系最亲近。
I called him Mike. Everybody else called him Chino. But he was cool to me. You know, that was my guy. I felt plenty love coming from him, you know.
我叫他迈克。其他人叫他奇诺。但他对我很好。你知道，那是我的哥们。我从他身上感受到了很多爱，真的。
Chauncey says that Mike was a biker guy with tattoos. He first met him in the Walmart parking lot. Mike had a black Cadillac and asked Chauncey if he could help at their store. Chauncey would ride his bike all over Milwaukee to give out flyers for the store.
钱西说迈克是一个有纹身的摩托车手。他第一次见到他是在沃尔玛停车场。迈克开着一辆黑色凯迪拉克，问钱西能不能在他们的店里帮把手。钱西会骑着自行车跑遍整个密尔沃基为这家店发传单。
I had a '52 Schwinn, you know, with a basket on the front of it. So I used to load up my basket. And I'd ride from down around the east side all the way up to Mayfield Road, you know what I'm saying, the south side, all by like, what you call it, Target, Walmart, over there, and I'd go to Bayshore. I was just everywhere on that bike just trying to promote the store. That's how much I cared about the store.
我有辆52年的施文自行车，前面有个篮子。所以我常把篮子装满。我从东区一直骑到梅菲尔路，你知道我在说什么，南边，像塔吉特、沃尔玛那边，还会去贝肖尔。我骑着那辆车到处跑，只是为了宣传这家店。我当时有多在意这家店啊。
These are, in fact, the far corners of the city.
这些地方实际上是城市的遥远角落。
I really pedaled it out for these people.
我真的为这些人骑得腿都酸了。
So Chauncey start passing the flyers out to peoples, and they wanted Chauncey to go out and let peoples know that they buy guns. And so I said, Chauncey, I said, that don't sound good to me.
所以钱西开始给人们发传单，他们想让钱西出去告诉人们他们买枪。于是我说，“钱西，”我说，“这听起来对我来说不太对劲。”
This is Chauncey's grandmother, Willie Campbell, who he was living with. She did not like this job from the start.
这是钱西的祖母，威利·坎贝尔，钱西住在那儿。她从一开始就不喜欢这份工作。
I knew there was something strange about it. Why would these guys set up some mess like that in this neighborhood, you know? It was in a poor black neighborhood and white guys, and what are you doing here?
我知道这事儿很奇怪。为什么这些家伙会在这社区搞这种乱七八糟的事情？那是一个贫穷的黑人社区，而他们是白人，你们在这儿干什么？
When the truth came out, Chauncey was charged with eight federal gun and drug counts. He was in jail for nine months and sentenced to no more than six months of house arrest and four years of probation. The way Chauncey sees it, he says that he was honest with the guys at Fearless Distributing. He was square with them. He put himself out for them. They should have done the same with him. If they couldn't, you know, tell him who they really work for, he thinks that Mike should have just told him to stay away from the store, not get involved.
真相大白后，钱西被控八项联邦枪支和毒品罪。他在监狱里待了九个月，被判处不超过六个月的居家监禁和四年缓刑。在钱西看来，他觉得自己在“无畏分销”对那些人是诚实的。他跟他们开诚布公。他为他们付出了一切。他们本应该也对他以诚相待。如果他们不能告诉他他们的真实身份，他认为迈克本应该告诉他离商店远点，不要卷进去。
You know, you could have just said, you fired, anything like that, man. I mean, if I'd had a chance to talk to him, I'd be like, man, you know you could've told me I could get, you know, what's right from wrong, because it's hard for me to understand what is wrong from right, you know what I'm saying?
你知道，你本可以只说，“你被开除了”，诸如此类的，伙计。如果我有机会和他谈谈，我会说，“伙计，你知道你本可以告诉我什么对什么错，因为对我来说很难分辨什么是错，什么是对，你知道我在说什么吗？”
They knew that he didn't know no better. And you a police. Ha-ha. That meant you supposed to be looking out for peoples.
他们知道他什么都不懂。而你们是警察。哈哈。那意味着你们本该是照看人民的。
In response to our questions about this, an ATF spokesman sent a statement saying, quote, "ATF does not target specific people based on their IQ or other mental health status." He said the ATF works with groups like the National Alliance on Mental Illness to make sure that agents are properly trained to deal with people they encounter who are mentally disabled or impaired.
针对我们关于此事的质询，一位ATF发言人发来声明称，“ATF不会基于智商或其他心理健康状况来针对特定个人。”他说ATF与“全国心理健康联盟”等组织合作，确保特工得到适当培训，以应对他们遇到的精神残疾或受损的人。
In at least one city, the way that ATF betrayed the trust of people who into their store so angered judges that agents were chastised from the bench. This was in Portland, Oregon, the ATF storefront operation near that school. An agent convinced two teenagers to have the name of their fake store, Squid's, which was also the agent's nickname, tattooed to their necks with a picture of a squid smoking a joint, so they'd be like a walking advertisement for the fake store. Again, here's Raquel.
至少在一个城市，ATF背叛进入他们商店的人的信任的方式，激怒了法官，法官在法庭上严厉斥责了特工。这是在俄勒冈州波特兰，那个靠近学校的ATF店面。一名特工说服两名青少年将他们伪装商店的名字——“鱿鱼”（Squid），这也是该特工的绰号——连同抽烟的鱿鱼图案一起纹在脖子上，这样他们就像是这家假店的活广告。再次声明，这是拉克尔说的。
The judge, in both in state and federal court for these two gentlemen, admonished the ATF and just found it pretty outrageous and ordered the ATF to pay for the removal of those tattoos, and said that is not conduct that they would expect out of federal agents.
法官在针对这两位先生的州和联邦法庭上，都告诫了ATF，认为这相当令人震惊，并下令ATF支付洗掉这些纹身的费用，并表示这种行为不是他们对联邦特工的期望。
I don't understand. What does the ATF get out of two guys having the logo of their fake store on their neck?
我不明白。ATF从这两个人把假店的标志纹在脖子上能得到什么？
The more I talk to folks who have done this kind of work, they said really it comes down to a lack of oversight and people just sort of losing perspective as to what you're there for and what you're trying to do.
我和越多从事这种工作的人交谈，他们就越说，这真的归结为缺乏监督，以及人们失去了作为特工应有的视角，忘记了你的初衷和你要做的事情。
The ATF, of course, is the agency that before all this brought us the Fast and Furious operation-- you may remember that-- that allowed about 2,000 guns to be sold to suspected gun smugglers. And then the agency lost track of most of the guns. Reporter John Diedrich says as best as he can tell, ATF started lots of these storefront operations to generate good headlines about the agency in the wake of that scandal.
ATF当然就是那个在这一切之前给我们带来了“速度与激情”行动的机构——你可能还记得——那次行动允许约2000支枪支被出售给可疑的枪支走私犯。然后该机构失去了对大部分枪支的追踪。记者约翰·迪德里奇说，据他所知，ATF启动许多这类店面行动，是为了在那场丑闻之后为该机构争取正面的头条新闻。
In its statement to us, the ATF defended the storefront operations but said that when it reviewed what happened at the Milwaukee store, it, quote, "found a number of deficiencies ranging from planning and oversight weaknesses to individual job performance issues. These matters have been fully addressed through a variety of major improvements put in place, including strengthened policy and procedure, increased national oversight, improved training, and revised procedures." They said, quote, "The ATF has made many substantial improvements and strengthened accountability for local operations."
在给我们的声明中，ATF为店面行动进行了辩护，但表示当它审查密尔沃基商店发生的事情时，它称“发现了许多不足之处，从规划和监督的弱点到个人的工作表现问题。这些事项已经通过采取的一系列重大改进措施得到了充分解决，包括加强政策和程序、增加国家监督、改进培训和修订程序。”他们表示，“ATF已经取得了许多实质性的改进，并加强了对地方行动的问责制。”
The ATF probably never would have had to make those substantial improvements. They never would have been embarrassed in the press or chastised by Congress and the Attorney General. It might not have shut down all its storefront operations-- which, by the way, it did-- if not for one mistake. It seems so random, this mistake, actually. But I guess if you make as many mistakes as they made in these storefront operations, any one might catch you.
ATF可能永远不需要做出那些实质性的改进。他们永远不会在新闻中感到尴尬，也不会被国会和司法部长斥责。如果不是因为一个错误，它可能不会关闭所有的店面行动——顺便说一下，它确实关闭了。这个错误似乎非常偶然。但我猜如果你像他们在这些店面行动中犯了那么多错误，任何一个都可能让你栽跟头。
It wasn't the squid tattoos or the low-IQ employees or getting robbed over and over. It wasn't the way they caught and charged suspects. It was that landlord in Milwaukee. If they hadn't trashed his place, or if they had just paid him promptly to repair it instead of fighting him over every penny, apparently, he wouldn't have called the newspaper. John and Raquel say the whole thing might never have come to light.
那不是鱿鱼纹身，也不是智力较低的员工，也不是一次又一次被抢劫。也不是他们抓捕和起诉嫌疑人的方式。而是密尔沃基的那位房东。如果他们没有把他的地方搞得一团糟，或者如果他们只是在损坏后及时付钱修理，而不是为了每一分钱跟他争执，显然，他就不会给报社打电话。约翰和拉克尔说，整件事可能永远都不会曝光。
John Diedrich and Raquel Rutledge's coverage of the ATF, there is lots more than this. It's at the Milwaukee Journal Sentinel website. If you Google ATF backfire, it'll get you there.
约翰·迪德里奇和拉克尔·拉特利奇关于ATF的报道，内容远不止这些。在《密尔沃基哨兵日报》网站上有更多信息。如果你搜索“ATF backfire”，就能找到。
Coming up, if a Border Patrol agent is not actually at the border, do you have to obey him? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，如果边境巡逻特工实际上不在边境，你必须服从他吗？这将在来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续后揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Every week on our show, of course, we choose a theme. Today's program, A Front, stories of setting up a business or operation that looks real, but is it as real as a pretends to be? We've arrived at Act Two of our show.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们当然都会选择一个主题。今天的节目主题是“掩护”（A Front），讲述设立一家看起来很真实，但实际上是否如其所表现的那样真实的生意或行动的故事。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。
Act Two, the border between America and America. So if you haven't spent much time in the Southwest, you might not know about this. But there are these Border Patrol checkpoints that are just like in the middle of highway interstates and other roads, not at the border, not even near the border. They're as far as 100 miles from the border.
第二幕，“美国与美国之间的边境”。所以如果你没在西南部待过，你可能不知道这一点。但在州际公路和其他道路中间有这些边境巡逻检查站，它们不在边境，甚至不在边境附近。它们距离边境最远可达100英里。
There are dozens of these interior or inland checkpoints across the country. They're mostly in California, Arizona, New Mexico, and Texas. But now there are a couple in Vermont, New Hampshire, and Washington state. You know that you're approaching one of these checkpoints, because the speed limit will suddenly drop to 45 miles an hour and then 25. You'll slow down, and you stop, you see these orange cones coming up. And then often there's this big sort of tent-looking structure, like, right in the middle of the highway.
全国有几十个这样的内地或境内检查站。它们大多在加利福尼亚州、亚利桑那州、新墨西哥州和德克萨斯州。但现在在佛蒙特州、新罕布什尔州和华盛顿州也有几个。你知道你快到检查站了，因为限速会突然降到每小时45英里，然后是25英里。你会减速，然后停下来，你会看到橙色的锥桶出现。通常还有一个看起来像帐篷的大结构，就在公路中间。
And then you stop, and you're right in the middle of the highway. And an agent in uniform, an armed agent walks up and asks you questions like, are you an American citizen? Sometimes he asks to look in your trunk. All this so they can catch undocumented immigrants and drug smugglers.
然后你停下来，你就在公路中间。一名身着制服的武装特工走过来，问你诸如“你是美国公民吗？”之类的问题。有时他会要求检查你的后备箱。这一切都是为了让他们能抓到非法移民和毒品走私者。
Reporter Debbie Nathan used to go through these checkpoints regularly when she lived in El Paso back in the '80s and '90s. And not long ago she discovered something that made her see these checkpoints in a whole new way. Here's Debbie.
记者黛比·内森在80和90年代住在埃尔帕索时，经常通过这些检查站。不久前，她发现了一些让她以一种全新的方式看待这些检查站的事情。下面是黛比的报道。
I had to go through the checkpoints a lot on Interstate 10 or I-25. And I dutifully complied. I didn't joke around. I answered their questions. If they asked to look in the trunk, I popped the latch. I treated checkpoints like TSA screening at the airport. And then, about a year ago, I ran across this video on YouTube that made the checkpoints seem less like serious law enforcement and more like the sitcom Reno 911 . It started with a guy in a red polo shirt filming himself as he rolls up to a checkpoint on Interstate 8 in California.
我经常要在10号或25号州际公路上通过这些检查站。我非常顺从地配合。我从不开玩笑。我回答他们的问题。如果他们要求看后备箱，我就拉开拉杆。我把检查站视为机场的TSA安检。然后，大约一年前，我在YouTube上看到了这个视频，它让这些检查站看起来不像是严肃的执法行动，而更像是情景喜剧《雷诺911》。视频开始于一个穿着红色Polo衫的家伙，拍摄自己开车驶向加利福尼亚州8号州际公路上的一个检查站。
What's up, man?
怎么了，伙计？
How you doing today, sir?
今天好吗，先生？
Good.
很好。
Are you a US citizen?
你是美国公民吗？
That's my business.
那是我的私事。
Well, it's our business to ask. Are you a US citizen or not?
好吧，询问是我们的工作。你到底是美国公民吗？
You can ask. That's fine.
你可以问。那没关系。
And you have to answer me, or I'll have to detain you until you can either tell me that  you're a US citizen.
你必须回答我，否则我不得不拘留你，直到你能告诉我你是不是美国公民。
Well, I don't have to answer you, because I have rights as an American.
好吧，我不必回答你，因为我有作为美国人的权利。
Sir, go ahead and pull over there behind that other vehicle, if you'd do me a favor.
先生，如果可以的话，请开到后面那辆车后面。
Nah, no thanks.
不，谢谢。
The video was called Top DHS Checkpoint Refusals. DHS, of course, stands for Department of Homeland Security, under which US Customs and Border Protection operates. Refusals means just what it says. I watched as one driver after another approached the border agents, greeted them politely, and then proceeded to be 100% uncooperative.
视频标题是《国土安全部检查站拒绝配合》。DHS当然代表国土安全部，美国海关和边境保护局就在其下运作。“拒绝配合”字面意思就是它说的。我看着一个又一个司机接近边境特工，礼貌地打招呼，然后开始百分之百地不合作。
How you doing?
你好吗？
US citizen, sir?
你是美国公民吗，先生？
Respectfully, sir, I do not have to answer that question.
恕我直言，先生，我没必要回答这个问题。
All of them refuse to answer questions or comply with commands.
他们所有人都不回答问题，也不服从命令。
Can you park your car right up there by those orange cones?
你能把车停到前面那些橙色锥桶那里吗？
[BACKGROUND LAW ENFORCEMENT RADIO CHATTER]
[背景执法部门对讲机杂音]
No.
不。
They'll sit in the main lane for traffic while cars back up behind them, refusing to pull off the highway to a secondary inspection area, or secondary, for short.
他们会坐在主行车道上，后面的车排起长队，拒绝驶离公路前往二次检查区，简称“二次检查”。
Where's the border at?
边境在哪里？
It's about 50 miles that way, sir.
那边大约50英里，先生。
50 miles?
50英里？
Yes, sir.
是的，先生。
Did I cross it?
我越境了吗？
The refuseniks say these stops are illegal, unconstitutional. Many cite the Fourth Amendment, which, just to refresh your memory, prohibits unreasonable search and seizure. And technically, these non-border Border Patrol checkpoints do constitute a seizure. If you're stopped, you have to wait for the agent's permission to continue on your way.
这些拒绝配合者说这些检查是不合法的、违宪的。许多人引用第四修正案，为了帮你回忆，它禁止不合理的搜查和扣押。从技术上讲，这些非边境的边境巡逻检查站确实构成了一种“扣押”。如果你被拦截，你必须等待特工的许可才能继续前行。
Do you mind rolling down the window, please?
你不介意把窗户摇下来吧，请？
That's as much as I feel like rolling it down, sir.
我就只能摇到这儿，先生。
Excuse me?
抱歉？
That's as much as I'm going to roll it down, sir.
我就只能摇到这儿，先生。
That's as much as you're going to roll it down to?
你只能摇到这儿？
Yes.
是的。
OK. Can you shut off the vehicle please, ma'am? Can you please shut off the vehicle?
好吧。你能熄火吗，女士？你能把车熄火吗？
That would be no. But the really crazy thing is that after several minutes of being stonewalled, the agents finally just give up. You can call their bluff, refuse to cooperate, and continue on your way.
那不行。但真正疯狂的是，在被阻挡几分钟后，特工们最终放弃了。你可以赌他们不敢真的把你怎么样，拒绝合作，然后继续你的行程。
Well, go ahead, go.
好吧，继续走吧。
Go ahead and go where?
去哪儿继续走？
Keep going on the road.
沿着路继续开。
OK. See you later.
好的。回头见。
I have developed a serious obsession with these checkpoint refusal videos. There are thousands of them on the internet now, and more are posted all the time with names like Illegal Checkpoints in America, Because This is America. At least once a week, I sit down and search for the new ones. I've made my husband watch with me and definitely bored some of my friends with them.
我已经对这些检查站拒绝配合的视频产生了严重的痴迷。现在互联网上有成千上万个这样的视频，而且不断有新的视频上传，标题诸如《美国的非法检查站》、《因为这里是美国》。我每周至少会坐下来搜索一次新的视频。我强迫我丈夫和我一起看，肯定也让我的朋友们感到厌烦了。
I love these videos partly because they're just terrific theater. Each driver has an individual style. Their personalities come out. Some are mellow when they confront the agents.
我喜欢这些视频，部分原因是因为它们是绝佳的戏剧。每个司机都有独特的风格。他们的个性显露无疑。有些人对峙特工时态度温和。
So who are you with?
那么你们是哪个部门的？
The US Border Patrol.
美国边境巡逻队。
What border am I on?
我在哪条边境线上？
Um, it's-- you're currently near no border. This is just a border control checkpoint.
呃，它——你目前不在边境附近。这只是一个边境管控检查站。
I'm in the United States, right?
我是在美国，对吧？
Yes.
是的。
So what's going on?
那这到底是怎么回事？
Others get angry in all the different political and psychological flavors of angry you can imagine. Some are Libertarian angry, some are human rights angry, some are Tea Party angry. There are simmering-just-under-the-surface angries and big-bountiful-bombs-bursting-in-air type angries.
其他人则会变得愤怒，包含你能想象到的所有政治和心理上的愤怒风格。有些人是自由主义者的愤怒，有些人是人权主义者的愤怒，有些人是茶党的愤怒。有那种潜在的压抑愤怒，也有那种慷慨激昂的爆发式愤怒。
We will not bow down to the illegal authority of the Border Patrol when we're not at the border. We are not at the border. You're 80 miles inside Texas. You have no authority.
我们不会向边境巡逻队这种非边境地区的非法权力低头。我们不在边境。你是在德克萨斯州境内80英里的地方。你们没有权力。
Calm down.
冷静点。
Are there any weapons in the vehicle, sir?
车里有武器吗，先生？
Calm down.
冷静点。
It's a stunning display of grassroots democracy in action, all these everyday folks with no organization, all questioning, arguing, debating their freedoms on the open road. Then there are folks who simply outwit the border agents. The guy in the red polo shirt, who you heard earlier-- the first one I ever saw-- is actually an evangelical pastor named Steven Anderson. This is how he got through a checkpoint back in 2011. As usual, the agent asks him, US citizen?
这是一个基层民主行动的惊人展示，所有这些没有组织的普通民众，都在质疑、争辩、讨论他们在大路上的自由。还有一些人干脆戏弄了边境特工。之前你听到的那个穿红色Polo衫的家伙——我见到的第一个——其实是一位福音派牧师，名叫史蒂文·安德森。这就是他在2011年通过检查站的方式。像往常一样，特工问他：“美国公民？”
US citizen?
美国公民？
Hey, actually, a more important question than that, you know, it's asked one time in the Bible, it's what must I do to be saved. And they said, believe on the Lord Jesus Christ and thou shalt be saved and thy house. So if you've got about 10 minutes, I can walk you through that in the Bible and show you how to be saved.
嘿，实际上，一个比这更重要的问题，你知道，圣经里问过一次，那就是“我当做什么才得救”。他们说，当信主耶稣基督，你和你一家都必得救。所以如果你有10分钟，我可以带你查阅圣经，告诉你如何得救。
I can't right now. I can't right now.
我现在没时间。我现在不行。
You can't. Now is not a good time?
你不行？现在不是好时机？
Nah, not while I'm at work.
不，在我工作的时候不行。
OK. All right.
好的。没问题。
Have a good one, sir. Thank you.
祝你过得愉快，先生。谢谢。
Yep. See you later.
好的。回头见。
I just want to point out that most of the challengers you've heard from so far are white men. From what I've seen in the videos, Latinos are hassled a lot more at checkpoints. The questioning is more suspicious. It goes on for longer. I saw one where parents were asked for their kids' birth certificates. And when Latinos are asked their citizenship, they answer, like, yes, I'm here legally. Are we done?
我只想指出，到目前为止你听到的挑战者大多是白人男性。从我在视频中看到的，拉美裔人在检查站受到的骚扰要多得多。询问更加可疑。持续的时间更长。我看到一个视频，父母被要求提供孩子的出生证明。当拉美裔人被问及国籍时，他们会回答，比如，“是的，我是合法在这儿的。我们要走了吗？”
Where were you born?
你在哪儿出生的？
I was born in Waco.
我出生在韦科。
OK, so are you a United States citizen, yes or no?
好吧，所以你是美国公民，是还是不是？
Yes, sir, I am.
是的，先生，我是。
But the agents want this guy to pull over into secondary, that secondary inspection area off the highway. And that's what Latinos challenge, frequent and prolonged detainments and searches. They think they're being profiled, and they want the agents to admit it.
但特工们想让这家伙驶入“二次检查区”，就是公路边那个二次检查区。这就是拉美裔人挑战的地方，频繁且长时间的扣留和搜查。他们认为自己被种族歧视了，他们想让特工承认这一点。
Park right there.
停在那儿。
What's the reason?
原因是什么？
This is an immigration inspection. I'm asking you now--
这是移民检查。我现在问你——
Why am I being inspected, though?
但我为什么要被检查？
Park right there.
停在那儿。
Why am I being inspected?
但我为什么要被检查？
Are you a lawyer or what?
你是律师还是什么的？
No. I'm asking why--
不是。我在问为什么要——
We're asking the questions here. Park over there.
是我们在这儿提问。停在那儿。
Why am I being inspected, though? I had the same trouble last week. I mean, why am I being inspected? Because I don't want--
但我为什么要被检查？我上周就遇到了同样的麻烦。我的意思是，为什么要检查我？因为我不想——
We have suspicion of something going on. Park over there. All we need is--
我们有理由怀疑正在发生什么。停在那儿。我们只需要——
Mostly checkpoint challenge videos are supposed to be gotcha videos. But half the time the agents actually seem calm and reasonable. And very rarely-- in fact, I've seen this exactly once-- an agent congratulates the challengers for exercising their rights. In that video, four kids who are maybe in their teens, chewing gum, roll up to a handsome young agent. He asks them if they're US. citizens. All they say is--
大多检查站挑战视频都被认为是“逮住你了”的视频。但有一半时间，特工实际上看起来冷静且讲理。而且极少数情况下——事实上，我只见过一次——一名特工祝贺挑战者行使了他们的权利。在那个视频里，四个可能是十几岁的小伙子，嚼着口香糖，开车驶向一名帅气的年轻特工。他问他们是否是美国公民。他们只说——
We're free to go?
我们可以走了吗？
Am I free to go?
我可以走了吗？
Yes. You know what, you guys are awesome for exercising your constitutional rights. I totally respect that.
是的。你知道吗，你们行使宪法权利的样子太酷了。我完全尊重这一点。
Cool.
酷。
Thank you.
谢谢。
A lot of the guys who come through here, they're jerks to us, and, you know, we don't appreciate that. But I totally appreciate you guys who are respectful. You don't want to talk, and we can't force you to do it. You guys have a good day.
很多过路的人对我们很粗鲁，你知道，我们不欣赏那样。但我完全欣赏你们这种礼貌的人。你们不想谈，我们也不能强迫。祝你们过得愉快。
Thanks, you too.
谢谢，你也是。
You too, sir.
你也是，先生。
The friendly agent is right. By law, the Border Patrol can't force you to answer their questions. But there's a lot of confusion about the legal side of this, by both the drivers and the agents, and lots of videos where both sides get it wrong.
那位友好的特工说得对。法律规定，边境巡逻队不能强迫你回答他们的问题。但在法律层面存在很多困惑，无论是对司机还是特工，有很多视频是双方都搞错了。
So after reading up on case law and talking to four lawyers, here's a quick rundown of your rights. Yes, you have to stop at a checkpoint. But according to the Fifth Amendment, you don't have to say anything, whether you're in the country legally or not. You do have to pull over to secondary when asked, but again, a lot of drivers refuse to go to secondary.
所以，在研究了判例法并采访了四位律师之后，这是你权利的简要总结。是的，你必须在检查站停车。但根据第五修正案，你不需要说任何话，无论你是否合法在美国。被要求时，你确实必须开到二次检查区，但再次强调，许多司机拒绝去那里。
In their arguments with one another, drivers and agents tend to refer to two main documents. One is a Supreme Court case called US versus Martinez-Fuerte. It was decided in 1976, and says many times in many different ways that the checkpoints aren't that intrusive, especially compared to how important they are from a law enforcement standpoint. Justice Lewis Powell gave the opinion announcement back in '76.
在他们彼此争论时，司机和特工往往会提到两份主要文件。一份是最高法院案件，名为“美国诉马丁内斯-福尔特”。它是1976年裁决的，多次以不同方式说明，检查站并不是那么具有侵入性，特别是考虑到从执法角度来看它们有多重要。大法官刘易斯·鲍威尔在76年发表了意见声明。
We hold that stops for brief questioning, routinely conducted at an official checkpoint, are wholly consistent with the Fourth Amendment. The intrusion on privacy and the limitation on freedom of movement in these situations are minimal.
我们认为，在官方检查站进行常规的简短询问，完全符合第四修正案。在这种情况下，对隐私的侵犯和对行动自由的限制是最小的。
So anyone who says it's illegal, i.e., unconstitutional, to screen for undocumented people at a checkpoint, they're wrong about that and a lot of challengers say it.
所以任何说在检查站筛查无证人员是非法的，即违宪的，他们在这方面是错误的，而且许多挑战者都会这样说。
I don't recognize or legal authority to ask me that question. And not only that, but I think it's unconstitutional.
我不承认你们有合法的权力问我那个问题。不仅如此，我认为这是违宪的。
A lot of the challengers.
很多挑战者都这么说。
Read the Constitution.
去读宪法吧。
Understand-- understand me, sir.
明白——明白我，先生。
Seriously, man.
说真的，伙计。
Understand this.
明白这点。
Read the Constitution.
去读宪法吧。
And if you don't happen to have a copy on hand--
如果你刚好手头没有副本——
Here's a copy of the Constitution of the United States. Here's a copy of the Constitution.
这是美国宪法副本。这是宪法副本。
Of the Constitution?
宪法的？
The other document that gets cited a lot in the checkpoint videos is the Immigration and Nationality Act of 1952, or the INA. But some agents misinterpret that, too.
检查站视频中经常引用的另一份文件是1952年的《移民与国籍法》，或INA。但一些特工也误解了这一点。
What right do you have, what cause do you have to suspect me, here, to pull me over?
你有什么权利，有什么理由怀疑我，在这里把我拦截下来？
Section 287 of the INA says--
INA第287条说——
Says what?
说什么？
Says that you must talk--
说你必须谈——
Answer all the questions you ask me? No, it doesn't. It says I have to stop. I'm here stopped, and I'm free to go on my way.
回答你问的所有问题？不，它没说。它说我必须停车。我已经停在这儿了，我可以自由地继续我的行程了。
The driver's right. The INA doesn't explicitly say you have to answer their questions. Other fun facts-- if agents ask to search your vehicle beyond just looking through the windows, if they want to look in your trunk, you can refuse, like this driver did.
司机说得对。INA并没有明确说你必须回答他们的问题。其他有趣的事实——如果特工要求搜查你的车辆，不仅仅是看一眼窗户，如果他们想看你的后备箱，你可以拒绝，就像这个司机一样。
So-- so you're saying that there's probable cause because--
所以——所以你的意思是存在“可能原因”，因为——
Not probable. Reasonable suspicion. There's a difference.
不是可能。是“合理怀疑”。这两者有区别。
OK, reasonable suspicion because I refuse a search?
好吧，因为我拒绝搜查就有合理怀疑？
Right. That's giving me reasonable suspicion that you could be hiding something, or else you'd be, sure, why not?
对。这让我产生了合理怀疑，怀疑你可能在隐藏什么，否则你会说“当然，为什么不呢？”
How is that so?
怎么会这样？
It's not so. For one thing, to justify a search agents need more than reasonable suspicion. They need probable cause, that is, a good reason to believe a crime is being committed. And this is important. Refusing to be searched, saying you can't look through my trunk, that's not probable cause. Neither is looking Latino.
不是这样的。首先，为了证明搜查的合理性，特工需要的不仅仅是合理怀疑。他们需要“可能原因”，也就是说，有充分的理由相信犯罪正在发生。这一点很重要。拒绝被搜查，说你不能看我的后备箱，那不是“可能原因”。看起来像拉美裔也不是。
The Supreme Court and the INA only authorize agents to search for undocumented immigrants. These days, they also search for drugs, contraband, and terrorists. Recent case law has allowed for this. It's legal. In terms of whether checkpoints work or not, whether they actually catch undocumented immigrants, here are some numbers.
最高法院和INA只授权特工搜查非法移民。如今，他们也搜查毒品、违禁品和恐怖分子。近期的判例法允许这样做。这是合法的。至于检查站是否有用，是否真的能抓到非法移民，以下是一些数据。
According to an internal report these checkpoints seize a lot of drugs but don't capture a lot of immigrants. Customs and Border Protection arrested about 7,600 individuals at checkpoints in fiscal year 2012. It doesn't say undocumented immigrants. It just says individuals arrested-- could be for drugs or anything. And only 1,800 of those were sent to US attorneys to be prosecuted. In the same year, 2012, one third of the total pounds of narcotics seizures by Customs and Border Protection happened at these checkpoints. As for what the checkpoints cost each year, those numbers aren't broken out.
根据一份内部报告，这些检查站查获了大量毒品，但并没有抓到大量移民。海关和边境保护局在2012财年在检查站逮捕了约7600人。这不是说非法移民。只是说被捕的“个人”——可能是因为毒品或任何其他事情。其中只有1800人被移交给联邦检察官起诉。在同一年，2012年，海关和边境保护局查获毒品总重量的三分之一发生在这些检查站。至于检查站每年的成本，这些数字并没有拆解出来。
You don't have to watch too many of these videos before you notice the checkpoint challengers tend to employ identical phrases when defying the border agents, as though they all went to the same disobedience school.
不用看太多这样的视频，你就会注意到，检查站挑战者在反抗边境特工时往往会使用相同的短语，就好像他们都上了同一所“不服从学校”一样。
Am I being detained?
我被拘留了吗？
This is the one you hear over and over again.
这就是你一遍又一遍听到的。
Am I being detained, sir? Am I free to go?
我被拘留了吗，先生？我可以走了吗？
Are you detaining me? Am I free to go?
你在拘留我吗？我可以走了吗？
I want to go free on my way. Am I being detained here? Are you detaining me here? Is this a detention?
我想自由地继续我的路。我在这里被拘留了吗？你在这里拘留我吗？这是一次拘留吗？
Am I being detained is something lots of people say to cops they think are stopping them for no good reason. But if you listen closely to one of the videos, there's a clue to how that language made its way to the checkpoints.
“我被拘留了吗”是很多人对他们认为无缘无故拦截他们的警察说的话。但如果你仔细听其中一段视频，就会发现这种语言是如何进入检查站的线索。
Did you get this idea from CheckpointUSA.org, sir?
先生，这个想法你是从CheckpointUSA.org得来的吗？
What are you asking me?
你在问我什么？
It's kind of hard to hear. The agent says, "Did you get this idea from CheckpointUSA.org, sir?" CheckpointUSA.org is an online storehouse of information about inland checkpoints and the laws and regulations that govern them. It was created by Terry Bressi, the second most prolific poster of these YouTube videos. I'll tell you about the most prolific poster in a minute.
很难听清。特工说：“先生，这个想法你是从CheckpointUSA.org得来的吗？”CheckpointUSA.org是一个关于内地检查站以及管理它们的法律法规的在线信息仓库。它是由特里·布雷西创建的，他是这些YouTube视频中第二多产的发布者。我一会儿再跟你说最勤奋的那位发布者。
From all I can gather, Terry started posting checkpoint challenge videos before anyone else, certainly before YouTube existed. And watching him work, it's like listening to the original version of a hit song that's been covered over and over again.
据我所知，特里在任何人之前就开始发布检查站挑战视频了，肯定是在YouTube存在之前。看着他操作，就像在听一首被翻唱过无数次的金曲的原始版本。
Who do you work for?
你为谁工作？
US Border Patrol.
美国边境巡逻队。
Am I being detained?
我被拘留了吗？
No. I'm asking you a simple question.
不。我在问你一个简单的问题。
Am I free to go?
我可以走了吗？
I'm asking you a question. You need to answer my question.
我在问你问题。你需要回答我的问题。
Am I being detained?
我被拘留了吗？
You need to answer my question, sir.
先生，你需要回答我的问题。
Am I being detained?
我被拘留了吗？
Sir, you need to answer my question.
先生，你需要回答我的问题。
Am I being detained?
我被拘留了吗？
I'm asking you what country are you a citizen of?
我在问你你是哪个国家的公民？
It's almost hypnotic when Terry does it.
特里做的时候几乎有催眠作用。
Am I being detained?
我被拘留了吗？
I'm asking you, are you being-- uh, what country--
我在问你，你是不是正在——呃，你是哪个国家——
Am I free to go?
我可以走了吗？
And he's very confrontational, cold and unrelenting. In regular life, Terry's a real introvert. He's chief engineer for an astronomical research lab and spends half his time working alone with telescopes at a remote observatory on a mountain in Arizona. That's why he passes through the checkpoints so often, to get to and from this job.
而且他非常有对抗性，冷漠且毫不留情。在日常生活中，特里是个真正的内向者。他是一家天文研究实验室的总工程师，一半时间独自在亚利桑那州一座偏远天文台使用望远镜工作。这就是为什么他经常通过检查站，因为要往返这份工作。
You know, I'm just trying to get home. Do you have a reason, you know, to stop me and interfere with my life? I don't care if you're wasting just three seconds of my life or three hours. It's my life. And unless I choose to interact with you, I shouldn't have to.
你知道，我只是想回家。你有什么理由，你知道，拦住我并干扰我的生活吗？我不在乎你只是浪费了我三秒钟还是三小时的生活。那是我的生活。除非我选择和你互动，否则我不应该被要求这样做。
Am I free to go, Agent D. Gilmore? Why aren't you allowing me to go on my way, Agent D. Gilmore?
我可以走了吗，特工D·吉尔摩？为什么你不允许我继续我的路，特工D·吉尔摩？
Park over there--
停在那儿——
This particular interaction lasts a minute and a half before Agent Gilmore says, you can put this on YouTube, I know who you are. Which begs the question, well, then why is he keeping Terry there? He knows he's a citizen. At the same time, after they tell Terry he can leave, he sometimes just stays and argues some more.
这次特定的互动持续了一分半钟，然后特工吉尔摩说：“你可以把它发到YouTube上，我知道你是谁。”这就引发了一个问题，既然如此，他为什么还要留住特里？他知道他是公民。与此同时，在他们告诉特里可以离开后，他有时还是会留下来继续争论。
You may go, sir.
你可以走了，先生。
I'm free to go? Why were these agents unlawfully detaining me?
我可以走了？为什么这些特工非法拘留我？
You may go, sir.
你可以走了，先生。
Why was these agents unlawfully detaining me?
为什么这些特工非法拘留我？
Have a nice life.
祝你生活愉快。
The most prolific poster of these videos also produces the most dramatic ones that I've seen. Not because they're full of angry back-and-forth with the agents or disputes over the law, but just because they are truly, totally weird and often very funny. You know a movement has really arrived when it gets its own comedian.
这些视频中最勤奋的发布者也制作了我见过的最戏剧性的视频。不是因为它们充满了与特工之间愤怒的来回争论，也不是因为法律纠纷，而仅仅是因为它们真的、彻底地怪异，而且往往非常滑稽。当一个运动有了自己的喜剧演员时，你就知道它真的到来了。
His name is Robert Trudell, and he lives in Arizona. In some ways he's the exact opposite of the refuseniks. In a lot of his videos, instead of jawing on and on at a checkpoint, he says nothing at all. He'll just stare at the agent, often gently smiling, bringing new meaning to the right to remain silent.
他叫罗伯特·特鲁德尔，住在亚利桑那州。在某些方面，他与那些拒绝配合者截然不同。在他许多视频里，他不是在检查站喋喋不休，而是什么都不说。他只是盯着特工看，通常带着温柔的微笑，赋予了“保持沉默的权利”新的含义。
Do you speak English? Huh? Hablas Espanol? [SPANISH] Are you a United States citizen, sir? Huh?
你会说英语吗？哈？你会说西班牙语吗？[西班牙语] 你是美国公民吗，先生？哈？
Robert Trudell is capable of the nuttiest shenanigans at a checkpoint. He's outfitted his Chevy Spark with anywhere from 8 to 13 little video cameras, capturing his stops from all different angles. Sometimes he'll sing to the agents--
罗伯特·特鲁德尔在检查站搞得出最疯狂的恶作剧。他给他的雪佛兰Spark装备了8到13个小摄像机，从不同角度捕捉他的停靠。有时他会对着特工唱歌——
[SINGING] I'm a man, man, man. I'm a--
[唱歌] 我是个男人，男人，男人。我是个——
Or speak German to them.
或者对他们说德语。
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
[说德语]
He comes through the checkpoints in different costumes-- an Afro wig and Janis Joplin sunglasses. He's driven through and ordered four hamburgers. One time he pulled up with his backseat stuffed with Mylar balloons. In that video, every question he answers, he sucks in a hit of helium first. Like when the agent asks, are you the only one in the vehicle--
他穿着不同的服装通过检查站——一个非洲假发和贾尼斯·乔普林的太阳镜。他开车通过并订购了四个汉堡。有一次他开着车过来，后座塞满了迈拉气球。在那个视频里，他回答的每一个问题，他都会先吸一口氦气。比如当特工问“车里只有你一个人吗”——
I'm not saying.
我无可奉告。
The agent says, "Fair enough. Any drugs in the vehicle?"
特工说：“公平合理。车里有毒品吗？”
That wouldn't be wise to reveal.
那透露出来可不怎么明智。
They let them through. Other checkpoint refuseniks next act brave. Robert Trudell is brave. One time he approached a checkpoint with his 12-year-old son in the backseat covered entirely with a sheet and an Afro wig on top of the sheet. For the last year or so-- since that video with his son, actually-- Robert prefers not to roll his windows down when he comes to a checkpoint.
他们放了他。其他检查站拒绝配合者接下来表现得很勇敢。罗伯特·特鲁德尔确实很勇敢。有一次他带着他12岁的儿子接近检查站，后座的儿子全身被床单盖住，床单上面戴着非洲假发。过去一年左右——自从那个和他儿子一起拍的视频以来，实际上——罗伯特更喜欢在接近检查站时不摇下窗户。
But I actually compromised when I ran into a situation that made it worthwhile to actually roll my windows down. I had run into a pack of jackasses along the highway. I don't know if you had seen that video, probably.
但我实际上是在遇到一个让我觉得真的值得把窗户摇下来的情况时做出了妥协。我在路上遇到了一群“笨蛋”（jackasses）。我不知道你是否见过那个视频，可能吧。
Literal jackasses, donkeys. He was late for a community theatre audition, but he drove by a herd of five sleepy-eyed jackasses shambling near the road. He pulled over his car and opened his window and started shooting a video in which he talked to them like they're Border Patrol officials.
字面意义上的“笨蛋”，驴子。他赶着去参加一个社区剧院的试镜，但他经过一群睡眼惺忪、在路边徘徊的五头驴子。他把车停到路边，打开窗户，开始拍摄一段视频，他在视频里对着驴子说话，就像它们是边境巡逻官员一样。
Yes, I'm a US citizen. Under whose authority are you making this stop?
是的，我是美国公民。你凭什么权威拦截我？
The animals stick their muzzles inside the window. Again, these are actual four-legged donkeys sniffing him.
动物们把口鼻伸进窗户。再次强调，这是真正的四足驴子在嗅他。
Am I free to go? Am I free to go?
我可以走了吗？我可以走了吗？
Then I try to act like these other checkpoint challengers, and I mimic the way they're talking after I drive off. I'm kind of ranting on.
然后我试图模仿这些其他检查站挑战者的行为，当我开车离开后，我模仿他们说话的方式。我有点在发牢骚。
Listen, I was surrounded by these jackasses once again! Held me up from my audition. This isn't going to make a good impression.
听着，我又被这群“笨蛋”包围了！耽误了我的试镜。这印象可真不好。
This is what I like about Robert Trudell. He makes fun of the whole checkpoint challenge mishegas. And he's just trying to come up with fun stuff for his viewers to watch. In a way, he's like an eight-year-old kid with a chemistry set. He just wants to see what'll happen, what will explode when he mixes things up.
这就是我喜欢罗伯特·特鲁德尔的地方。他嘲笑整个检查站挑战的疯劲。而且他只是在尝试为他的观众寻找有趣的东西看。在某种意义上，他就像一个带着化学套装的8岁小孩。他只是想看看会发生什么，当他把事情混在一起时，什么会爆炸。
Robert says he makes about $8,000 a year from the videos, from ads on YouTube. His most popular video, the one that's gotten almost a million views, is not funny. In fact, it's kind of chilling. He's not wearing any costumes, not saying anything strange. All he's doing is sitting in his car at a checkpoint near Pine Valley, California, taking photographs of the agents and a local sheriff, all of whom are trying to get him to roll his window down.
罗伯特说他每年通过YouTube上的广告从视频中赚大约8000美元。他最受欢迎的视频，那个获得近百万次观看的视频，并不好笑。事实上，它有点令人不寒而栗。他没穿任何服装，没说任何奇怪的话。他所做的只是坐在加利福尼亚州派恩谷附近的检查站车里，拍摄那些特工和当地治安官，所有人都试图让他摇下车窗。
They pull him over to secondary and try to talk to him through the glass. Finally they give up, but they don't let him go this time. Instead an agent approaches with a little tool balled up in his fist and swings his arm back.
他们把他拉到二次检查区，试图隔着玻璃和他说话。最终他们放弃了，但这次他们没让他走。相反，一名特工手里拿着一个小工具走过来，挥动胳膊。
So he--
所以他——
[GLASS SHATTERING]
[玻璃碎裂声]
--you know, smashes the window open, and--
——你知道，把窗户砸开，然后——
Hm?
嗯？
Get out of the vehicle.
下车。
Violence like this doesn't happen a lot in these videos, but it does happen. Agents also broke the window of that pastor I mentioned earlier, Steven Anderson. They tased him and bloodied his face.
像这样的暴力在这些视频中并不常发生，但确实会发生。特工们还砸破了我之前提到的那位牧师——史蒂文·安德森——的窗户。他们对他使用了电击枪，使他满脸是血。
In Robert's case, he says the agents seized his cameras, put him in handcuffs, drove him far away to a holding cell, and detained him for hours. Then they drove them even farther away to El Cajon, California, let him out late at night at a bus station, and drove off.
在罗伯特的情况下，他说特工扣押了他的相机，给他戴上手铐，把他带到很远的拘留室，关押了几个小时。然后把他带到更远的加州埃尔卡洪，深夜把他扔在一个巴士站，然后开车走了。
Robert plans to file a claim for damages and lost income. But he says the one thing the bothers him about the whole experience is that he didn't have cameras outside the car to get better video of the whole thing. And it hasn't deterred him from making lots more videos.
罗伯特计划提出损害赔偿和收入损失的诉讼。但他表示，关于整个经历，最让他烦心的是他车外没有摄像机来获得更好的视频记录。这并没有阻止他制作更多的视频。
And can you just spell out again, like, why, just why?
能不能再详细说一下，为什么，到底为什么要这么做？
To test, kind of do a test to the system, to see how things operate.
为了测试，算是对系统进行测试，看看事情是如何运作的。
But to test the system why, exactly?
但测试系统究竟是为了什么？
To understand it better.
为了更好地理解它。
Well, why do you want to understand it better? Why this system?
嗯，你为什么要更好地理解它？为什么是这个系统？
Because I'm close to it, I'm surrounded by it. I can't go anywhere without going through this system. And the people in the community I'm in are trapped in it.
因为我离它很近，我被它包围了。我不通过这个系统哪儿也去不了。而且我所在的社区里的人都被困在里面。
All right, so we're coming up on a Border Patrol checkpoint here. Where are we now?
好了，我们要接近边境巡逻检查站了。我们现在在哪儿？
Gila Bend.
希拉本德。
Gila Bend, Arizona.
亚利桑那州希拉本德。
On our way back from interviewing Robert Trudell, my producer, Sean, and I went through a checkpoint, not to do a challenge. We just had to get to the airport. And Border Patrol was set up on that road. We were about 65 miles from the border. Sean pulled out his recorder to see if we could get a comment from the agents about the videos.
在采访罗伯特·特鲁德尔回来的路上，我和我的制片人肖恩经过了一个检查站，不是去进行挑战。我们只是得赶去机场。边境巡逻队就设在那条路上。我们距离边境大约65英里。肖恩拿出他的录音机，想看看能不能让特工对这些视频发表评论。
Hi.
嗨。
Hello, sir, How are you?
你好，先生，你好吗？
No surprise, they said they couldn't talk to us and referred us to the main Customs and Border Protection office in Tucson. I requested an interview about the checkpoint videos. They sent back a long written statement that said nothing about the videos.
不出所料，他们说他们不能接受我们的采访，并把我们转到了位于图森的美国海关和边境保护局总部。我请求就检查站视频进行采访。他们发回了一份长长的书面声明，其中对视频只字未提。
Here's part of what it said instead. Quote, "Checkpoints restrict smugglers from access to transportation hubs, roadways, highways, and different routes of egress. It is not unusual for Border Patrol agents manning these checkpoints to engage in conversations with the public regarding their travels. Brief questions to dispel any concerns are intended to complete the encounter with minimum disruption to traffic."
声明中部分内容如下。引述：“检查站限制了走私者进入交通枢纽、道路、高速公路和不同的出口路线。边境巡逻特工在这些检查站管理时，与公众就其行程进行交谈并不罕见。旨在消除任何担忧的简短询问，目的是在对交通造成最小干扰的情况下完成检查。”
We also requested an interview with the headquarters of Customs and Border Protection in DC and asked them for statistics on how successful the checkpoints are at catching undocumented people and drug smugglers. After going back and forth with them for a week, in the end they answered none of our questions.
我们也请求采访位于华盛顿特区的海关和边境保护局总部，并询问他们关于检查站在抓获非法移民和毒品走私者方面有多成功的统计数据。在与他们沟通了一周后，最终他们没有回答我们的任何问题。
I did talk to a former Border Patrol agent named Ephraim Cruz, who said something interesting about the checkpoints and how they work. Cruz is famous in Border Patrol circles. He was a whistle-blower, and after that was brought up on charges of transporting an undocumented person into the States. He was acquitted. Sean and I asked him if he ever caught any undocumented immigrants himself. He said he did, but in the flanks, the area around the checkpoint as far as three miles out.
我确实采访了一位名叫埃弗拉伊姆·克鲁兹的前边境巡逻特工，他说了一些关于检查站及其运作方式的有趣的话。克鲁兹在边境巡逻圈子里很有名。他是一名举报人，在那之后被控向美国境内运送非法移民。他被判无罪。肖恩和我问他是否自己抓获过非法移民。他说他抓过，但是在“侧翼”，即检查站周围远至3英里内的区域。
In the flanks?
在侧翼？
In the flanks of the checkpoint.
在检查站的侧翼。
Not at the checkpoint itself.
不是在检查站本身？
No. Not that I recall, no.
不。据我所记得，没有。
You never found an undocumented person at the checkpoint?
你在检查站从来没有发现过非法移民？
Not that I recall.
据我所记得，没有。
This is the thing I didn't understand until talking to Ephraim. The checkpoints have the effect of squeezing undocumented immigrant traffic out to the sides, out to the brush and desert, where some get caught, many get lost, some die. The Border Patrol has reported that more than 6,000 migrants were found dead on the US side of the border between 1998 and 2013. That's not the intention of the checkpoint, of course. But Ephraim says patrolling the flanks has become part of the overall checkpoint strategy.
这就是我跟埃弗拉伊姆谈话前不明白的事情。检查站的效果是将非法移民的交通挤压到两侧，挤压到灌木丛和沙漠中，在那里有些人被抓，许多人迷路，有些人死亡。边境巡逻队报告称，1998年至2013年间，有超过6000名移民在边境的美国一侧被发现死亡。当然，这并不是检查站的初衷。但埃弗拉伊姆说，巡逻侧翼已经成为整体检查站战略的一部分。
It's effective in the sense that people who know the checkpoint is there and have intentions on smuggling a human load through will circumvent the checkpoint, and roving patrols will actually intercept those loads. And from my experience, the checkpoint gives some of the public a sense of the Border Patrol doing something.
这很有效，因为那些知道检查站存在并打算走私人力货物的人会绕过检查站，而机动巡逻队实际上会拦截那些负载。根据我的经验，检查站让公众觉得边境巡逻队确实在做点什么。
Not long ago I ran across a phrase that experts and analysts use, "security theater," meaning security measures that are mostly for show. If Ephraim Cruz is right, the checkpoints are a kind of security theater, brightly lit stages in the middle of the highway that send undocumented people elsewhere to get caught. The checkpoint challengers are unwilling actors in that drama, unpaid extras. And so they turned things around and started telling a different story, casting the border agents in absurdist productions that they're directing and filming themselves.
不久前我偶然发现了一个专家和分析师使用的短语，“安全戏剧”（security theater），意思是为了展示而进行的安全措施。如果埃弗拉伊姆·克鲁兹是对的，检查站就是一种安全戏剧，高速公路中间灯火通明的舞台，把非法移民送到别处去被抓。检查站挑战者是那场戏剧中不情愿的演员，没拿报酬的临时演员。于是他们扭转了局面，开始讲述一个不同的故事，将边境特工编排进他们自己导演和拍摄的荒诞作品中。
Debbie Nathan in New York.
黛比·内森，纽约报道。
Act 3, Ellis Island. So now we have this story about people putting up a front in a very different setting than these previous two stories. This is putting up a front in a family and in a doctor's office, depending on how you see it. Ayelet Waldman says that her dad, he's a bookish man, he's a very smart man, but no man is everything that his kids want him to be.
第三幕，埃利斯岛。现在我们有了这个故事，讲述人们在与前两个故事完全不同的背景下设立“掩护”。这是在一个家庭和一个医生办公室里设置的掩护，取决于你怎么看。阿耶莱特·沃尔德曼说她的父亲，他是个书呆子，他是个非常聪明的人，但没有哪个男人是他孩子想要他成为的那种人。
I've tried a lot of different ways to get inside my father's head, but he has no interest in self-revelation. Ask about the history of the kibbutz movement or Stalin's five-year plans for the Soviet economy, and he'll deliver a classroom-ready lecture complete with footnotes.
我尝试过很多种方法进入我父亲的头脑，但他对自我揭示毫无兴趣。问他关于基布兹运动的历史或斯大林对苏联经济的五年计划，他会发表一篇课堂级别的演讲，甚至带上脚注。
But ask him how he feels about something? He'll pretend his hearing aids aren't working. I've tried to combat his reticence in all sorts of ways, including sneaking personal queries into discussions of the topics that actually do interest him. You have no idea of how difficult it is to shoehorn a question about your father's first divorce into a conversation about the schisms between the Ihud and Meuhad kibbutz factions.
但问他对此有何感受？他会假装助听器坏了。我尝试过各种方式来对抗他的沉默，包括把个人问题偷偷塞进他真正感兴趣的话题的讨论中。你不知道把关于你父亲第一次离婚的问题硬塞进一场关于基布兹派系分裂的对话中有多困难。
That's why it was downright astonishing when a while back, he handed me a stack of old mini cassette tapes. They were recordings of his psychotherapy sessions from 30 years before. He said, you're the writer in the family. Maybe you can do something with these.
这就是为什么当他前不久递给我一叠旧的迷你磁带时，简直令人吃惊。那是他30年前心理治疗课程的录音。他说，你是家里写东西的。也许你可以用这些做点什么。
Here's what I hoped for. My father would bare his soul to a psychologist. He would confess all of his fears and anxieties. He'd tell the truth about his feelings for his wife. He'd describe his disappointments with his children. I'd finally understand why he and my mom have stayed married for 50 years when they can barely tolerate being in the same room for 50 seconds. Maybe he'd cry. Maybe he'd talk about me. This is what I actually heard.
这就是我所希望的。我父亲会向心理学家敞开心扉。他会承认他所有的恐惧和焦虑。他会说出对他妻子的真实感受。他会描述他对孩子们的失望。我终于会明白为什么他和妈妈在几乎无法忍受在同一个房间待50秒的情况下，还能维持50年的婚姻。也许他会哭。也许他会谈到我。这是我实际听到的。
Well, the whole idea of the kibbutz is that it's based on a premise of truth and honesty between people and cooperation and not taking advantage of others and all this crap.
好吧，基布兹的整个理念是基于人与人之间的真诚、诚实、合作，以及不占他人便宜等等这些废话。
Yes. The history of the kibbutz movement. And here's my dad's therapist chiming in with Communism.
是的。基布兹运动的历史。这是我父亲的治疗师在附和“共产主义”。
And look what Lenin wrongly said, that the [BLEEP] state would wither away.
看看列宁错误地说了什么，说[哔]国家会消亡。
But instead of withering away--
但与其消亡——
You have a dictatorship of the proletariat, which he really meant over the proletariat, because we know it ain't of the proletariat.
你拥有了无产阶级专政，这其实是他所说的“在无产阶级之上”的专政，因为我们知道它根本不是“属于”无产阶级的。
My father's psychologist, Albert Ellis, was actually a pretty big deal. One of the inventors of cognitive behavioral therapy, he died in 2007. He's widely considered to be among the most important psychotherapists in history. The three 40-minute psychotherapy sessions I listened to were exactly like every conversation I've ever had with my dad, except with one major difference. Ellis cares as much about this crap as my dad does. He's totally engaged.
我父亲的心理学家艾伯特·艾利斯，实际上是个大人物。认知行为疗法的发明者之一，于2007年去世。他被广泛认为是历史上最重要的心理治疗师之一。我听的那三段40分钟的心理治疗，和我跟我爸所有对话一模一样，除了一个主要区别。艾利斯和我的父亲一样关心这些废话。他完全投入进去了。
I've had lots of opportunities, incidentally, to join the immoral majority, the money-making majority, and sell my soul to the Ladies' Home Journal and McCall's magazine. I can write slop for them, you know.
顺便说一句，我有很多机会加入不道德的多数，赚钱的多数，把我的灵魂出卖给《淑女之家》和《麦考尔》杂志。我可以为他们写些垃圾，你知道的。
He doesn't even sound like a psychologist. He sounds like my dad, like a crotchety old man with a huge chip on his shoulder. Again, here's Ellis.
他听起来甚至不像个心理学家。他听起来就像我父亲，像一个心里有极大不满的固执老头。再次重申，这是艾利斯。
Too damn bad that we've got a [BLEEP] world where if you really want to make money, you lick the ass of the Reader's Digest. That's how to make money in this world. And they never published a single thing of mine. And I never got a [BLEEP] thing in McCall's or the Ladies' Home Journal. Best I could do is Cosmopolitan or something like that, who kept some of my stuff.
太该死了，我们生活在一个[哔]的世界里，如果你真的想赚钱，你就得拍《读者文摘》的马屁。这就是在这个世界上赚钱的方法。他们从未发表过我的任何东西。我也从来没在《麦考尔》或《淑女之家》上得到[哔]任何东西。我能做的最好就是《大都会》之类的，他们留了一些我的东西。
The very rare moments where Ellis and my dad actually talk about my dad's life and his emotions last for maybe five minutes at a stretch at most. Like here's my dad explaining the resentment he had for the wealthy people he dealt with at his fundraising job.
艾利斯和我父亲真正谈论我父亲的生活和情感的极其罕见的时刻，充其量也就持续五分钟。比如这里是我父亲在解释他对他在筹款工作中打交道的富人所持的怨恨。
Well, I've got to learn how to accept these people for what they are. If I go on resenting them, I won't be able to work in any [BLEEP].
好吧，我得学会如何接受这些人原本的样子。如果我继续怨恨他们，我就没法在任何[哔]里工作了。
Exactly right.
完全正确。
But it's true. I have this, you know-- and when somebody is, well, you have this resentment. Where the hell does this come from?
但这是真的。我有这个，你知道——当某人是，好吧，你有这种怨恨。这到底是从哪儿来的？
You know, I think it largely, partly comes from your own feelings of inadequacy that I'm not making a million bucks and being an idealist, too.
你知道，我认为它很大程度上，部分来源于你自己“我没挣一百万”的自卑感，而我是个理想主义者，也是。
Now we're getting somewhere, right? But as soon as they start digging in, it's like they both panic at the prospect of actually talking about something real. And they scramble away to a safely neutral subject, like how many books Dale Carnegie sold.
现在我们谈到点子上了，对吧？但当他们开始深入挖掘时，就像他们俩在真正谈论一些真实的事情时感到恐慌。他们会乱作一团，逃向一个绝对中立的主题，比如戴尔·卡内基卖了多少本书。
He sold about 10 million copies, and still sells very well. Yeah. Still sells.
他卖了大约1000万册，而且卖得依然很好。是的。依然卖得很好。
Among the other topics my dad and Albert Ellis limned with great thoroughness when they were supposed to be getting to the root of my dad's anger issues, or whatever the hell it was that he went to therapy to talk about? Ralph Nader.
在我的父亲和艾伯特·艾利斯非常彻底地研究的其他话题中，当他们本应该深入探讨我父亲的愤怒问题，或任何他去治疗想谈论的废话时？拉尔夫·纳德。
Now, Ralph Nader doesn't sell his soul at  all, because he's willing to do what he does and supported with his own effort.
现在，拉尔夫·纳德一点也不出卖他的灵魂，因为他愿意做他所做的事，并用他自己的努力支持它。
The Teamsters' alleged crime connections.
卡车司机工会的所谓犯罪联系。
But obviously some people in the Teamsters are simply closely linked to the mafia.
但很明显，卡车司机工会里有些人简单地与黑手党有着密切联系。
This is when we learn more fun facts about Ellis.
这是我们了解艾利斯更多有趣事实的时候。
I'm a member of the union, AFRA.
我是工会AFRA的成员。
The insights into my parents' marriage I was hoping for, the feelings he has never been able to express, none of that is in there. My four brothers, my sister, me, he doesn't even mention our names. My mom? The woman he spent hours of every day fighting with? She comes up exactly once. If you spent your evenings and weekends yelling at and being yelled at by your wife, wouldn't you talk about it in therapy? So I had a few questions for my dad.
我所希望的对父母婚姻的洞察，他从未能表达出的感受，这些统统没有。我的四个兄弟，我的姐妹，我，他甚至没提过我们的名字。我妈？那个他每天花几个小时与之吵架的女人？她只出现过一次。如果你每天晚上和周末都对着你的妻子吼叫，并被她吼叫，难道你不会在治疗中谈论它吗？所以我对我父亲有一些问题。
Hello?
喂？
Hi, Dad, how are you?
嗨，爸爸，你好吗？
Good.
很好。
My dad's an energetic 89-year-old. He spends his days reading three or four books at a time, flies overseas by himself. He's lived on a diet of Keebler fudge-stripe cookies for so long-- he's up to a pack a day-- that my kids say he's turning into an elf. I asked him why it was that he never talked about our family in therapy. Why is it that we don't even come up?
我父亲是一位精力充沛的89岁老人。他每天花时间同时读三四本书，独自飞往海外。他依靠基布勒软糖饼干的饮食习惯维持了太久——他达到了一天一包——以至于我的孩子们说他快变成一个小精灵了。我问他为什么在治疗中从不谈论我们的家庭。为什么我们甚至都没被提起？
What I was trying to do is get my head together. And one of the things that we were supposed to discuss-- and this is why we went to Ellis-- was that my marriage was suffering.
我当时试图做的是把我的大脑整合在一起。我们本应该讨论的事情之一——这就是我们去找艾利斯的原因——是我的婚姻正在遭受痛苦。
But you know, Daddy, you never talk about your marriage almost at all.
但你知道，爸爸，你几乎从没谈过你的婚姻。
Well, yeah. That's too personal, really. Yeah. So.
好吧，是的。那太私人了，真的。所以。
Talking about his marriage is too personal for therapy.
谈论他的婚姻对治疗来说太私人了。
So you didn't talk about it.
所以你没谈。
No. I wouldn't talk about my marriage, even not to Ellis.
没有。我不会谈论我的婚姻，即使对艾利斯也不会。
Why didn't you talk about it to him?
你为什么不跟他说？
Oh, we got sidetracked on all kinds of things.
哦，我们在各种事情上跑题了。
I had all these questions, questions about our relationship, and questions about how much you and mom were fighting. And then you gave me the tapes. And I thought, [GASP] he's giving me the tapes because he wants me to know. And then--
我有所有这些问题，关于我们关系的问题，关于你和妈妈吵架有多严重的问题。然后你给了我磁带。我想，[喘气]他把磁带给我，是因为他想让我知道。然后——
Then I didn't disclose anything.
然后我什么也没透露。
Yes, exactly. You didn't disclose anything.
是的，没错。你什么也没透露。
For years, I thought if I just found the right way to talk to my dad, he would finally open up. But eventually I just gave up. And then he gave me those tapes. And even though I know my dad, and I should've known exactly what I was going to hear, I was stunned all over again. It's crazy that even when we're grown, even when we know from long experience that someone is who they are, we still keep hoping that they might be different.
多年来，我以为只要我找到和父亲交谈的正确方式，他最终就会敞开心扉。但最终我放弃了。然后他给了我那些磁带。即使我了解我的父亲，即使我本该知道我会听到什么，我还是再次感到震惊。这太疯狂了，即使我们长大成人，即使我们从长期的经验中知道某人就是某人，我们仍然保持着希望，希望他们可能会有所不同。
Ayelet Waldman, she's the author of Love and Treasure and many other books. Her story was produced with Alix Lambert, whose film, Mentor , comes out on video on demand and DVD next month.
阿耶莱特·沃尔德曼，她是《爱与宝藏》及许多其他书的作者。她的故事是由艾利克斯·兰伯特制作的，艾利克斯的电影《导师》下个月将在视频点播和DVD上发布。
They left my place in shambles, I mean like a college fraternity or something, just trash everywhere. They tore out some walls and they rewired some stuff and caused a leaky roof.
他们把我的地方弄得一片狼藉，我的意思是像大学联谊会什么的，到处都是垃圾。他们拆了一些墙，重新布了一些线，导致屋顶漏水。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。